here in Australia this baby red kangaroo
called a Joey has been out of the pouch
for just two days and mom is getting
ready to give birth again how does this
work well let's find out
a pink kangaroo embryo the size of a
Lima Bean pops out it's blind and deaf
and yet somehow it's got to find its way
to the mother's pouch its hind legs
which will someday allow the kangaroo to
jump nearly 30 feet are now just useless
buds it's going to have to drag itself
upwards six inches using its four limbs
to climb through the forest of its
mother's thick fur this quest will take
about three minutes once inside the
pouch it searches out mom's nipples and
starts feeding this embryo will remain
latched on to one nipple for 34 weeks
once it leaves the pouch it'll continue
to suckle from its mother for another
four months now here's the amazing part
this tiny pink critter was actually
conceived many months ago in an earlier
stage it remained in a kind of suspended
animation called a diapause while mother
tended to the youngster that's now
outside the pouch the mother kangaroo
now produces two separate and distinct
kinds of milk one for the embryo the
other for Joey once she reaches sexual
maturity the female breeds for 8 to 12
years in times of drought
she doesn't breathe but otherwise she
keeps her cycle of diapause embryos and
Joey's going strong usually where
there's a fertile female there are also
males fighting over her the newcomer is
on the right over six feet tall and the
early money is on his becoming the alpha
male here why because only the
sub dominant male kicks in these
competitions and the roux on the left is
doing all the kicking the dominant male
having won the right to woo Bob claims
his mate the scent of the female
attracts another male suitor but the
dominant male scoffs at this upstart
hear that that's the sound of a dominant
male kangaroo scoffing the result of
this mating will produce an embryo that
will grow a few days and then become
dormant until the embryo we observed is
out of the pouch like an air traffic
controller
mom has to keep these babies stacked up
in line ready to take off and she does